thank you all for coming
welcome to this uh new series um that we
uh launched with the uh the engineering
workforce development of the center for
codon network
and the yellow quantum institute uh we
are delighted to be here my name is
florian carl i'm the manager the manager
of the
uh the yale quantum institute and um i
will be moderating this uh this tunnel
uh with my colleague arizobaya um so
this series um we
we are kickstarting this series with one
event uh today
uh about uh prepare for college because
we've realized that
um building quantum technology is
something that requires a lot of people
with different background we need
physicists we need electrical engineer
we need computer scientists software
engineer chemist
there's a lot of trades that we need and
it can be very overwhelming
to consider a career in quantum science
and information
and so by by attending this session
today um you will hear from college
students from staff and faculty
in the field what it's like to work in
quantum and we hopefully you can get
advice
on navigating the various pathway that
you can take
so um this um these events will be
recorded so a little bit of technical
details on the zoom
we can only you can only see and hear
the panelists
um you have a feature at the bottom of
your screen
that has the q a panel
so if you click on it you should be able
to type your questions
and then you can also put a thumbs up on
the question you want
answer the most and so the the most
recursive question will go to the top
and then
uh russell and i will go through them
and ask to the panelists
um there's also um closed captioning if
you want and this uh this will be
recorded
and you can watch it later on demand
before we start um i would like to
introduce my colleague russell
vayette and he will be the second
murderer with me
and he's gonna say a few words thanks
lauren so yeah i'm russell ballier i'm
with the
center for quantum networks uh and
specifically with the
engineering workforce development team
i'm the assistant director
uh so just real quick a little bit about
the center for quantum networks
it's a national science foundation
funded center that just got started uh
late last year
uh and we are we are a part of
uh 10 different institutions or sorry
there are 10 institutions in our center
including
yale i'm specifically with the
university of arizona which is the lead
institution
and so the center for quantum networks
got started because
we one of our big goals is to help lay
the foundation for a socially
responsible quantum internet
which some of you have probably heard
about uh hoping that this is gonna spur
new technology industries
uh competitive marketplace for quantum
service providers and
application developers for the benefit
of all like i said i'm specifically with
the engineering workforce development
team so
a lot of what our goals are include
trying to develop the future workforce
to be a part of the quantum internet and
help develop
it and also help develop the quantum
network
um so a lot of what we do is uh outreach
um within trying to educate people and
try to get people interested in the
quantum internet
technologies and all this kind of stuff
that some of some of you are going to
hear about
today so uh real quick if there are any
teachers out there
um we are looking for some classrooms to
actually run some virtual field trips
where
students will get to kind of have an
interactive peak
into some of the cool stuff that happens
in these labs that are doing things
related to the
quantum internet and quantum networks so
and so i don't think florian mentioned
this
but why how he got interested in quantum
but
uh to be honest i actually have no
background background in quantum
i'm a i have a phd in geology so a lot
of this is new to me and
i'm going to be learning a lot but um
for me
i think kind of one of the cool things
about quantum is just how
interesting it is and just kind of the
weird crazy stuff
that goes on with uh with quantum
so thanks lauren
thank you russell um so before we
introduce uh the panelists um
since we cannot see you we've we thought
they would be fun to have
a little poll um happening in the chat
so
you will see a poll and then you can
tell us what does your interest are you
interested in in stem in the carry on
team and so we can learn a little bit
more and make sure that we target
or answer to uh to to your needs so
the the poll should pop up in your
screen right now
and then i will start uh with the the
panelists um so maybe let's start
with um so you can start um turning on
your webcam
uh thank you all for being here and then
we can start with uh maybe uh shantanu
if you want to uh introduce yourself and
tell us uh
all about uh what you do
yeah uh first of all thanks so much for
having me here
um you know uh i would really enjoy
um going to such an event if i were
starting off and if i were interested so
um i'm happy to be here my name is
chanting
i recently graduated from yale this past
december
while i was there i studied physics and
math and
i started off in quantum information
science by doing research with professor
girvin
one of the other panelists here today
later i i uh did research in in
professor devery's group
in quantum engineering
superconducting systems quantum
platforms on to which we realized
um qubits and other cool things um i
also founded the
yale undergrad quantum computing org and
we can talk a bit about that later
but through that i was able to meet a
lot of cool people and
make a lot of cool projects yeah so
really happy to be here
hello thank you
um ayala do you want you to go next
yeah i would love to thank you so much
for having me my name is ayelet kalpas
i'm a rising sophomore el majoring in
physics
and i'm the director of partnerships at
uqc
the organization that shantanu started
this past year
so it was actually a dark november night
during quarantine when i received an
email from yqi about
the upcoming lecture that night why you
should care about quantum computers and
i know plans for that night so i decided
to be a fun night activity for my family
i
set up the tv in our living room and we
started watching and i hadn't really
realized that quantum computers were
something that existed outside of marvel
movies
and as i sat there watching i just
realized that this was an amazing
exciting
interdisciplinary field that combined a
lot of my interests
and i started to see a future for myself
within that field
and then a few days later i got an email
about the formation of uqc this
undergraduate quantum computing club
so i joined and since then i've only
grown more and more enthusiastic about
quantum computing and my place in it
at yale i'm also the outreach chair for
women in physics
i'm involved with the student film
festival i'm currently co-directing a
mini documentary
and i'm actually going to be doing
research with professor girvin this
summer and i'm really looking forward to
that
thank you so much
well this is the perfect transition then
for steve to to go next
hi i'm steve girvan i'm a professor of
physics and professor of applied physics
at yale
i also have temporarily a half-time
position at brookhaven national
laboratory where i'm the director of the
co-design
center for quantum advantage one of the
five
national quantum information science
research center is recently funded by
the department of energy
i'm the faculty advisor to the club that
shantanu and iolet
are helping run
and i'm a theoretician
i work with pencil and paper and
computers rather than
hardware but i i think closely about
quantum hardware and i'm part of the
team that invented
the basic architecture for using super
connecting qubits
to to try to build quantum computers
that's been
adopted by google and ibm and righetti
and other
companies around the world and lots of
academic places
and maybe one fun fact about myself
i grew up in a small village in northern
new york state there were five kids in
my high school class
thanks a lot um and then uh our
last finalist kelly do you want to
introduce yourself please
sure good morning everyone my name is
kelly ratliff and i
am on the recruitment and admissions
team
for the college of engineering here at
the university of arizona
which as you heard is one of the partner
institutions for the center for quantum
network so i'm really excited to be here
today i am not a scientist or a
physicist
but i help support the students who will
be our future scientists and physicists
so
i work with incoming first-year students
and incoming transfer students and
help them determine their path forward
into a stem engineering or maybe even a
quantum career
so i'm really pleased to be a part of
this excellent group and i look forward
to
chatting with you all today thanks for
having me
thank you uh and i can follow up on that
saying that
there's also a lot of career like when
we think about carrier in
quantum we automatically think about uh
scientists uh we think about a lot of uh
people like working on quantum science
but there's also
a lot of people in the background one of
the last event that we will have in this
series would be with uh
alternative careers for people who are
supporting all the stuff and all these
efforts
um so we will have that probably uh in
december
um okay let's uh kick start things but
uh sorry let's
start these things with uh our first
question so
i think this question will uh be uh more
for um
or two uh panelists antennae um can you
tell us a little bit more like
what's your experience in in college and
like how did you
uh find out what you wanted to do and
how did you decided to study quantum
yeah sure i'm happy to start it off so
one of the best pieces of advice i
received from any professor my first
year
was one of my professors was talking
about who how kids who found success
in their high school career are often
really too scared to pivot to something
else and try something new
i actually entered yale as a
neuroscience major i felt very secure in
that
and then during my first year i fell in
love with physics
and i felt like should i change should i
not and then because of this professor's
advice i decided to go for it
and now in my second year since i
started yale i'm falling in love with
the intersection of physics and computer
science
specifically quantum computing and i
guess my biggest piece of advice is to
maintain an open attitude
take classes that interest you and be
willing to embrace
changes in what you want to study
yeah absolutely um you know i think when
i
entered uh when i was first interested
in quantum information sciences
because of all the potential right like
the potential of quantum advantage
the potential to impact you know create
impact across
industries that really interested me and
the reason why i actually stuck
to quantum information science um i mean
it was absolutely very interesting
but it was because of the people around
me because of the communities that i was
able to
take part in because of my uh
roommate from my second year uh how we
kind of work together you know
work through some of these concepts and
and i think because of that community
i was able to really like prosper or and
continue
um to develop my interest into now it is
my passion
and what i'll probably continue to do
for the rest of my life yeah
uh since you're since you were talking
can you tell a bit more about
the uh the yellow quantum computing club
that you organized
absolutely yeah absolutely and that you
helped us
launch florian um but yeah last fall we
created the yale undergrad
quantum computing group um looking back
i think there are three reasons that i
um start up this group the first was to
make that community right that i talked
about because and i was lucky enough to
have a suite mate who was interested in
the same thing
but having like a club having sort of an
organization
um there for students who are just
starting out
uh who are really interested and who
need that sort of support network
would be very useful so that was the
first thing to build community
the second thing was um because i wanted
to reach people who
didn't um who were interested in quantum
computing but
they didn't have this sort of background
in physics or computer science right
they came from
other stem fields they came from
non-stem fields
and they had that amazing potential to
make impact but they didn't
i mean no one had really like told them
that you know this is something that you
can do
so yeah so it was it was a cool club
where
people from interdisciplinary
backgrounds could come in and create
impact and the third reason
was because i wanted to work on cool
projects and i wanted to work on cool
projects with people from
different backgrounds and different
perspectives i think that's where the
coolest projects come from
when you have people that come from
different backgrounds yeah so
and i think all those three reasons were
achieved and will continue to
i guess like be met in the coming years
thank you um the fact that we're mixing
so many people
across so many discipline is also um the
challenge of this
of this technology and and this field
because we
are going to need a lot of people and so
there's there's not a single
it's great for all of you trying to
consider carrier in in quantum but it's
also a little bit difficult for us to
give you
one answer because you can enter the
field in so many different ways
um that's something that's uh very
challenging and i think the
uh the us is trying to uh
to uh help that um by launching
initiative
like the the the quantum force uh the
centre for quran network
for all the different hubs national hubs
of the quantum initiatives
uh and it's um is it something that you
can talk a little bit more about
steve about this center
yeah so
first thing to understand is that
quantum
computing is at a very early
stage right you know it's maybe we've
invented the quantum abacus or
or uh you know some very crude
versions of computers exist but they're
not that
useful yet and so we have many
problems to solve and it's going to take
a while
so young people your age
are are needed to come into the field
to help us solve these problems over the
next 10 or 20 years or however long it
takes
and so
the center that i direct c2qa
is a very large national center there
are
24 institutions uh
five federal labs 18 universities
and ibm as our industrial partner
because they have
experience you know physicists are not
system uh builders and or even
computer scientists and so you know
people with industrial experience are of
course
valuable and
the the technology technology readiness
level
is just very low there are many many
problems to solve and you can
contribute uh whether you're a
mechanical engineer
electrical engineer a computer scientist
a physicist
a material scientist a chemist
they're just we're trying to invent an
entirely
new type of technology and
no one person or even no
group of people all from the same
background could possibly
solve all the child engineering
challenges that
uh that we face so
uh it's um that again means there are
many routes for you to enter this field
and it means that centers like the one
that i direct are important
precisely because they bring together
people who haven't been
talking to each other before so i
now have a chance i'm now collaborating
with
computer scientists that i had you know
i just
i know very little about computer
science that they know
i know a little they know a little bit
about physics and a little bit about
quantum computing and we're working
together
to try to think about how do you
write programs for quantum computers how
do you compile them
how do you get them to work even though
the hardware is still
not very reliable
there are people that are um
electronic you know work with high-speed
electronics there are
people that um
you know just come from all kinds of
backgrounds
and so it's it's
really an opportunity to
[Music]
build communities with diverse
backgrounds
to try to tackle these big challenges
well speaking of that like how do you um
how like
you have all these avenues to enter this
field like how do you decide
um which one is good for you um can uh
one of you uh panelists tell me like if
you had like what kind of experience you
had
to sort of like try different things
like is there
tools online that you can use like what
kind of activities you can do
i'm hinting at maybe a hackathon just
just some
just some hints this one does one of you
want to talk about that
yeah i can say a bit about um expand on
that hint
yeah we had this fantastic event the
quantum coalition hack
that you know isla have helped lead and
this is this is really incredible event
because
i mean we had sponsorship from companies
across the world
so our biggest sponsors were ibm and
cubecontrol
in google and we had a ton of other
sponsors
and i think the coolest thing though was
that we had
2 000 people sign up one thousand
one thousand four hundred people
participate in some way and
200 teams of of like three to five
people submit projects and this
this shows how much interest there is
out there and this hackathon was
conducted completely
virtually right so without needing to go
into a lab
without needing to even have very um
a very strong laptop we had sponsors
that would provide online interfaces
that you could use um if you didn't have
very powerful computing tools at home
i think this is a testament to how many
resources now exist
on the cloud that are free to use um
i so i i also um i i also am an
ibm kisket advocate so i've had some
experience with with kiskit with
contributing to
um kiskit which is open source and i
can i can at least for kisskit
there's a there are a ton of uh
tutorials there's yeah there's a
wonderful online interface
ibm quantum experience um and there's a
really
vibrant community out there so there's
like a like a popping slack
channel or you can just ask you know if
you're coming in from
if you're an industry professional if
you're a college student if you're a
high school student you can just go
there and get some help and
get started and this is one of the many
you know many
tools out there so definitely
if you're interested i would say there
are tools
out there to support you there are
communities out there to support you
and the best way to get started is to
you know go through one of these intro
tutorials
if you're interested in quantum
information science
so the one i just want to add good good
one
thank you so much i just want to add one
more note on the hackathon so i had just
joined uqc as director of partnerships
but as i mentioned i'd
literally had my first quantum computing
lecture a month before
and then it was my responsibility to
reach out to all of these sponsors and
ask them to join our hackathon
and it felt like a pretty big request
and i was very nervous being a beginner
to the field
but i was amazed by how dedicated these
sponsors were
to bringing in the next generation and
specifically to bringing in new
perspectives
i think that's kind of what's special
about the quantum computing community
is that people really understand the
need for interdisciplinary collaboration
and they're really open to bringing in
beginners that's just been really
reassuring and exciting for me
as a beginner to this field
um so there's a so all the resources
online like i think if you just uh
do a quick search on on on google about
these different things you will be able
to find them
um a few uh things that we can point out
is that um so ibm has a lot of resource
uh kiskit has
a lot of also uh resources and tutorial
google
has also a series of videos
online um microsoft is starting to
ramp up their their programming so they
have more and more things and
one thing that um i can from that if you
give me a second so i can change my site
um there's this uh school um so you can
see
on my webcam um the qubit by qb.org
is a website um that has a ton of
resources
and they are currently uh hosting summer
camp for middle school
high school and college students and uh
we have also
a quantum i mean not we but like they
also have a quantum summer school
for uh researchers so there's uh there's
a lot of things uh available
and one of the the advice that i will
give you if you if you're interested in
the fields but you don't know exactly
what to do
um it's really to try to follow
tutorials there's like some very short
exercise and some like it's almost the
shape of a homework and you can like
uh starting with a compiler and like try
to to test
um your very first code on the quantum
computers
and so to follow on that steve could you
tell us a little bit more because i know
that you use
the ibm experience for your classes
um can you tell a bit more about the
interaction of the of the students with
these
quantum computers sure so
i'm presently teaching an undergraduate
course at yale physics 345
and the you you don't have to have any
background in
physics to take it the only
prerequisite is to know a little bit
about
linear algebra solving sets of
simultaneous equations basically
and um so
[Music]
i give you know some lectures on the
background and then when students have a
little background they can start
programming and doing homework
assignments
on the ibm quantum experience
florian is putting up the
the one of the interfaces that you can
use it's very simple
drag and drop graphical interface to
start
you don't even have to write code you
just drop
different quantum gates or operations
into a circuit
and there's a lot of
[Music]
online tutorials
uh with ibm q and with kiskit to show
you how to use this
and it's a lot of fun students really
enjoy
uh playing this is completely free you
can have
access i you know uh as a
professor i i'm a member of the
education network at ibm and so we have
a little
extra access to the machines but anybody
anywhere in the world is welcome to log
in and start playing with these at no
charge so
if you're curious to learn a little bit
about
uh you know try your hand at some simple
very simple
programs then you can just uh go ahead
and start today
we have a question in the the q a panel
for you shantanu
um so isaac said that he imagines that
creating
an undergrad club on such a complex and
advanced subject
is not pretty easy uh he he would be
interested in knowing how you prepared
and study in order to like empower
enough people to propose the creation of
this club
yeah that's a it's a good question and
you know something that i grappled with
when i was going to start this when i
was thinking of starting this
organization
you know because yale has a really rich
history
in quantum information science and
quantum engineering and here i thought
you know
um is it is it okay for me to create a
club
like this and i think what motivated me
was we had an interest meeting
and there were a lot of undergraduates
that were interested in in such a club
right there and there
they came we we actually i like to look
at the numbers and we had
um i think we had like 10 or 15
different majors outside of
physics and computer science and and
math
um that were interested in joining such
a club right that wouldn't have had
access to these amazing resources this
like rich
history and graduate community at yale
if not for a club like this so that's
why i that's why i continued with it
that's how i got the motivation and
asked for how i got the
resources to support this i found that a
lot of the resources were
were already kind of um there and i just
had to reach out to
ask so i asked professor girvin and he
was really helpful
and i asked florian he was very very
helpful and
i think the best thing that i i i could
have done
and i did was gather a really talented
board
of people right who were for
about such a such adventure so i i
should note you know that's like more of
like a motivation
and a little bit of advice surround
yourself by people who are interested
and passionate
if you're trying to start a club like
this and on a more practical note
this quantum coalition hack that we
mentioned before
is not going to be contained to quantum
the quantum coalition hack it it's
actually
kind of like a cool network of
universities
across the world so if you if you're if
you're at a university and you need some
um support in starting a club you can
just join
our discord go to our site quantum
coalition.io
and we're also going to host a webinar
where we
kind of talk about how to create a club
and this is i mean
i know there are a ton of resources out
there and so we're going to try to work
with everyone so that we're not like
so that was so that we're so that we're
taking full advantage of all the
synergies
um so the point the main point there is
that there are people who are interested
in such a thing and um
there are a lot of people who are
interested in working with you to create
um
cool clubs like quantum computing clubs
and and i can add out i'll add to this
that um
there is an an opinion piece uh written
i think six months ago uh
and then the the main concern and the
main limiting factor of
quantum science will be the workforce
because we're at the point where
we don't have enough people trained on
all of this field and so
the the reason why it's so important
these days and
why everybody uh from the tech giants to
the university to be high school
teachers that like really trying to
bring together the workforce is because
that's going to be the limiting factor
and so you can i think you can use that
to your advantage and like
reach out to people uh and say like oh
i'm this i'm
a high school student i'm interested in
doing that can you help me do that and
like i'm pretty sure you will have all
your answers like yes please
here like we can help you with this
thing these are some resources here like
you can read onto that
um and so that's really something that's
going to be so
the field is it's challenging because
it's a new field and so it's going to be
a lot of work for everybody but
there's also we are in really good shape
uh right now this is the perfect time to
join this field
um because that's going to be the the
time where everybody wants you and
somebody with a quantum background will
be really looked for
on the job markets after that and so
since
uh this this session is to to prepare
for for college
and or like if you're like on a on your
first year of college
maybe we can ask kelly like what are the
uh the advice
that you can give as a recruiter to like
what how to how can you put your best
chances um to uh to enter a college and
and then study this field
sure so i can kind of speak from the
perspective of our engineering program
at the university of arizona and it's
good to keep in mind
that every institution is going to be
different in terms of their process
and the programs they offer but
as we mentioned you know it's the cool
thing about this field is that you can
combat it from a variety of different
backgrounds so i loved islets advice
about having an open mind and i think
that is
super important as you're going through
your college search process
as you're thinking about what you want
to major in and it is okay
as a high school student to not know
today
or when you're applying what exactly you
want to do for the next four years so
that's
one of my biggest pieces of advice too
is to just
be curious have an open mind and pursue
the things that you really
enjoy um so the way our program at the
university of arizona is set up
in our engineering school is actually
all of our engineering students come
into the college
they don't choose a major right away so
we have a built-in first semester course
where you actually meet all
now 16 we just added a major in software
engineering
that was announced uh this week so we
have 16 programs now that you get to
pick from
so if you have a career path in mind you
may find
a variety of majors that really speak to
what your future goal is so if your
future goal is in quantum
you may want to pursue physics instead
of engineering you may want to pursue
software engineering or material science
i know
our department head here in material
science at the university of arizona
um he's also working on a quantum
computing project using sound um so
there's a lot of different ways that you
can add on to your college experience
outside of your major so these research
opportunities internships
those are all things that can supplement
you as you're going through
so it's okay to not know right now
exactly what the next four years are
going to look like
just keep an open mind and i would say
as
you know my advice as an admissions
person is if you're interested in a
career
in any one of the science fields or
engineering or math
in high school pursue as many of those
courses as you can as
as much math especially calculus based
math
for engineering that's super important
for us math and science in high school
take whatever you can get involved in
clubs
uh whatever they may be whether it's
coding or robotics or whatever interests
you
and you're going to have a great
foundation coming in having taking those
courses
and it's really going to set you up for
success you know transitioning into
college level
physics chemistry calculus all of those
things coming in your first year so
there's lots of ways to slice it but um
i would say
the the more that you can pursue those
foundations in high school
the more prepared and confident you'll
feel coming into a university setting
where you're using all of those skills
and building upon them
thank you we're going to take a question
from jimmy in the
in the q a panel uh he said that he
completely recently completed the ibm
uh qxq
coding school and this is like a lot of
online school that you can take
and most of the positions i've seen are
for phds or engineers
uh and so um it's i think that's the
case
for now a lot of people since we're at
the very beginning
of the of the field um the it's it's
much easier
for a research center to develop this
kind of work
but i think it's going to expand to
different kind of
uh different kind of uh of position but
um can
can one of you in the panel tell us like
what do you think the
uh the the workforce will be in in the
short term and in the long term like
will it be a shift between like only
phds or is it gonna be the part the turn
of like
more engineers more masters what kind of
diploma should you get
um it for now i know it's a bit of a
tough question because we don't know
what the field's going to look like but
if one of you can
uh can uh try to uh to hinder that that
would be great
i mean i i could actually maybe chime in
a little bit about this
um so just kind of based on some of the
research
that's out there just because things are
and some of this is my opinion too
but just kind of early on since a lot of
this is still being figured out and
developed
that there's kind of a need for phd phds
and
kind of scientists kind of lay that
groundwork
and then later on for you know for
master's
students and so on to kind of then come
in and
execute these things so that's kind of
my thought
yeah i could add a little bit i mean you
know
right now quantum computers are
hand assembled mostly by phds
mostly physicists some engineers but
you know the field is evolving so
rapidly and there's no there's no way
that we can
[Music]
you know expect somebody to to become an
electrical engineer and then take
another six years and get a phd also in
quantum physics we have to
find ways for
people to start contributing giving them
give them
easy ways to learn enough about
the basics of quantum so they can bring
their expertise from whatever field
they're in to bear
on the numerous problems that we're
we're trying to solve so
this is actually a big question
[Music]
uh in industry and for the federal
government right now how do we learn how
to do that
i'm part of a panel that was at an nsf
national science foundation workshop to
try to figure out
just how do you create courses for
undergrads
to get them introduced to quantum and
what should the requirements be
and what should you teach and what
should you teach at for the
beginners and the more advanced students
and we're still
it's such a new field we're still
figuring this out
um but and going back to the things that
kelly was saying earlier um
you know what is the best you can
contribute you can get into this field
from
any almost any field
um and what you should pick to work on
in
college is just whatever you're excited
about
it doesn't matter um
when you go you know you can use that as
a
some expertise in that area plus a
little study
or one course or you know personal
effort to learn a little bit about
quantum to get yourself
an entree it really doesn't matter it's
more important to be passionate about
something and
use that passion to to
uh than to say oh i want to get into
quantum
and i should study this even though it's
not the thing i'm most excited about
that's that's a mistake
um and you know you're gonna
you're gonna major in something in
college you may change your mind
what what your major is uh
that's that's what college is for it's
the one time in your life when you can
explore
and try out things
and after college you you know you might
decide to go to graduate school and get
a master's degree and it might be in a
different field it might go you might
move from
electrical engineering to physics or
vice versa that's
not uncommon and so uh
don't you know don't try to think
there's some
absolutely single best route to take
there are many ways in and you should
take the one with the most interesting
scenery along the route
that's a very good point to talk about
personal experience
when i was never really like in high
school i really hated school i didn't
really want
to to continue so i went to a
vocational school for two years and then
slowly and slowly i was like well
you've you've done enough work and then
maybe you can do an engineering school
in the back and then
and then i i went to a grad school and
then i went to postdoc and then you end
up in this position and so
really um like if you have a plan that's
great but also there's a ton of
opportunities everywhere and so if you
if you limit yourself to one thing you
might miss out on really
fascinating opportunities that you might
have um yeah college is a is a really
good time for that
and to try to figure out um what to um
what to do and what you like and what
you don't like because sometimes it's
also very
uh much easier to figure out what you
don't like uh you take one
class of intro of i don't know um
something about uh i don't want to like
pinpoint on the matter because
somebody's gonna be mad
since we have so many uh people
presented here but um yeah you will
you will quickly realize if you if you
like the subject or not and then
you can you can decide what to do yeah
maybe i can
add a quick note from the perspective of
someone who
you know was looking at some of these
job opportunities um both to collect
them for our club
and also just because i was a little bit
interested um
because i'm working currently um and i'm
working for a bit before i go to grad
school
i'm working as a software engineer and
that's my first point so the two the
skills that you develop
when um working in in quantum
information science working on these
projects are very transferable and that
goes both ways right like you can come
in from any background you can also
um pursue any like a lot of different
things afterwards so it's a very
worthwhile effort um and
when going to college um
give is yeah do we want to do and also
if you're interested in something don't
be afraid of like really diving deep
and and um getting your hands dirty uh
yeah that will be well you that will be
time well spent
um yes so yeah so another thing i want
to note is
i i looked at these job postings and
i've seen some really cool roles pop up
so at companies like amazon and google i
see software developer rules
pop up that don't require a phd
background
so this is kind of like to the point of
building the infrastructure
right um necessary to achieve you know
something like quantum advantage
um at a large scale you don't just you
don't need like you don't just need
physics uh phds um you also need
software engineers and a lot of other
people like throughout the stack
right so to speak of quantum computing
um
yeah so there are a lot of transferable
skills and there are
opportunities that are already popping
up and will continue to pop up
maybe that's a that's a good time to um
present the
the upcoming events that we have in this
series um give me
one second um here we go because since
there's so many careers um
we have a series of events so the next
one will be
for um preparing for grad school because
of course as somebody mentioned
phd are very important right now but
then we have
we have some more panels to cover like
most of the
most of the different positions that you
can get so grad school will be in june
in august we will have four faculty
members for young
uh postdocs uh who wants to go in
academia and try
to get tenure in the university in
october we'll have
a panel on startups so all the the work
that has been done
uh by the startups and most of the uh
most of the quantum computer uh the big
player in the role
uh started from startups from university
so it's i think we have the phase where
the startup are transitioning into these
big
uh tech giants so that's that's going to
be an exciting
uh an exciting time and then in december
we'll have uh
four industry jobs and uh what you can
do to make yourself
more valuable in the field and i think
that will be
one that um would be very interesting
like we had a couple of questions about
that
in in the chat um we are almost running
out of time
uh maybe we can look back to each of you
and
you can tell us like you know in a
minute or so like what um
like your uh your hot take on uh how we
could uh prepare for college and like
what's
what's the advice you can give our
audience
um maybe i should uh start who wants to
start
all right let's i'm going to pinpoint on
that uh i'll let you to start
uh the the last word on that
yeah sure i do want to reiterate what i
said before i want kelly echoed
about maintaining an open attitude and i
also want to emphasize that you can find
a way to contribute to quantum if you
have a desire to learn
it is often an intimidating field but
you if you have that desire to learn no
matter
how beginner you are you can find a way
to contribute
uh something yeah absolutely
um so on a i guess
more general advice note uh try to find
someone with
um with whom you can actually learn this
material that's really helpful to have
someone there to motivate
you and on a more practical note
if you're interested in like quantum
information science in particular and
actually running these circuits i would
say
the only requisite would be
learning a bit about how matrices uh
work with each other so like how they
add and how they multiply vectors and
i think that's that's like from a
practical standpoint um
and in terms of opportunities you don't
have to wait for
an internship you don't have to wait for
um
like some opportunity to come come up
in terms like a formal program you can
start contributing
to open source uh projects if you're for
example if you're interested in computer
science
um you can find the kiskit uh the
githubs the kiskit githubs
um at repos and you can and you can
start
contributing right away so yeah so
don't be afraid to get started find
someone to help motivate you
um and bounce off ideas with and uh
if you can if you're interested um try
to learn a bit
about linear algebra i think they'll be
really helpful
russell
so i think i'll echo kind of some of the
stuff that's come up here is
find find a major find a field that
you're interested in you know do some
research about the different pathways
um we've talked about some of them today
but i think find something that you
really enjoy and that you can be
passionate about and
you'll find a way in to you know
the quantum workforce um and just keep
an eye out for different opportunities
to get involved with
outreach or some of the extracurriculars
that we've talked about i think
that's going to be really important
because that's more of a informal kind
of laid-back way to kind of test
you know if you're going to enjoy this
and and making connections with people
too at those events
teddy sure i guess
uh one maybe kind of different thing
that we haven't discussed that's on my
mind this week
is may 1st is you may have heard his
traditional kind of national college
decision day so
i've been talking to a lot of high
school students and parents this week
who are just really worried
they don't want to make the wrong
decision and in their
words and so i would just say
don't worry a lot about something like
that
there are so many wonderful programs in
the us
and around the world related to these
fields
and really it's just about finding a
place that you feel
like as a place you want to spend the
next four years that feels comfortable
to you that feels welcoming to you
and so don't worry so much about picking
the wrong
school or the wrong program or the wrong
major
you'll find your path as you go through
college
and really it's about finding a place
that feels like home to you so if you're
able to do
campus visits when you're doing your
college search or or talking to
other students i know one of the things
i do a lot my job is
connect high school students to current
undergrads to talk about things like
research or their experience or
or internships or whatever it may be so
just have an open mind
apply to any place that interests you
and then
if you can try to visit and and focus on
picking a place that feels like you
and and you'll be successful
thank you steve last words
uh yeah so you know
like just as it's easier to learn
languages when you're young i think it's
easier to learn
mathematics when you're when you're
young
and so the as shantanu mentioned really
the minimum
mathematics you need to know about to
enter this field is linear algebra how
to solve
simultaneous equations how to work with
matrices and vectors
and there are
[Music]
wonderful websites like three blue one
brown where you can
see amazingly uh wonderful
videos that teach you these things
and um you can start there
you can take a course when you get to
college
uh and i would i would
learn that first i would
you know probability and statistics
turns out to also be an important part
of quantum because
the measure there's a certain randomness
in the way quantum mechanics works
and that's a very very important
area anyway in modern data-driven
society and so that'll be a skill even
if you end up
not going into quantum or not even going
into science
it'll make you a better citizen you can
you can understand
um you know
the statistics that people are using to
argue
for different policies so
i would uh if you had to pick one thing
to suggest you study
it's discrete mathematics
all right so we're going to conclude on
this uh on this thing thank you all
uh to the panel uh thank you all for
attending and thank you also for your
time
um for all the panelists who are here i
hope um you learned
a lot about what we're doing we have uh
posted in the chat
a lot of uh links um so we had some of
the
um the the videos that we're talking
about um people want brown some of the
the websites
that you can find with the resources and
then otherwise uh google is really
helpful if you do a quick search you
should find a
ton of things and don't forget to uh to
ask people so that would be great
thank you all and uh we hope to see you
next time
so yeah our next event will be uh if i
pick the date we'll be on june 18
at 2 p.m pacific time and 5 p.m
uh eastern time so if you're interested
in that um please
let us know you are in your registration
you had a place to um received email for
the upcoming event so we will be send
that
we will send that shortly thank you all
and have a great
rest of your morning rest of the
afternoon or everywhere you are in the
world
thank you